thanks Dan thanks to the organizers for
inviting me it's always great to be here
so I guess my goal today is to just give
kind of a high-level introduction to
what differential privacy is tell you a
little bit about how you can actually
achieve it so stop me any of time if you
have any questions okay so let me start
with the snap how many of you of you
have seen this map okay yes you get very
different reactions from different
routes okay so this is a map of London
in 1854 when there was a big cholera
epidemic called the Broad Street
epidemic 600 people died in a week
almost the whole neighborhood evacuated
and nobody knew what was causing it at
the time people didn't know what caused
cholera and this gentleman John snow
went there and he drew this map so he so
this is the map he drew where each of
the black dots is one case of cholera
and he stated this map and basically
from this map concluded that cholera is
waterborne and it was this bump right
here that was causing it so if you look
at all the black dots basically all the
black dots lie in the Voronoi cell of
that particular pump what you would now
call over and I said of that particular
pump all these houses were getting their
water from that pump that was infested
with cholera and this actually founded
the field of Epidemiology so I think
this was one of the first illustrations
of the use of private data for public
good and I guess as we all know there's
a lot more data now and we can hope to
use a lot more of it for more public
good and this is probably what was on
William Bell's mind back in 97 when as
the governor of Massachusetts he decided
that all the medical records of the
state employees so the state of
Massachusetts is the insurer for all all
state employees so it has access to all
their medical records
he decided this is a large amount of
useful data mining it could actually be
very useful so you decided let's make it
public of course this is private data so
you can't just publish everyone's
medical records so he did what was kind
of at the best possible anonymization at
the time so people all personally
identifiable information was stripped
off and the data was released it was
about a week before he got a letter in
this mail with his own medical records
and Latanya Sweeney was the person
responsible for that she was then a
graduate student at MIT and here's what
she did she went to the city of
Cambridge paid them $20 to get the voter
rolls the voter rolls have a fair bit of
information like this name address party
affiliation zip code date of birth
gender and some of these fields were
also present in the medical data set
it's reasonable to say that the zip code
is not a personally identifiable
information
tons of people live in my zip code same
for the date of birth and gender but
what she realized when she did a join on
these two data sets was that the
intersection is actually very highly
personally identifying in this data set
basically if you're under join on these
two data set
most people here become unique including
William Burt
so this is I think an instance of kind
of the risks of using private data for
public good which is that making such
high dimensional data private is a very
difficult task
we don't necessarily know what kind of
information can be identifying when
coupled with other rocks daily data sets
in this case a very simple obviously yet
I said the water list is enough to
uniquely identify William weld and
everyone else in the database but it's
not just limited to these three
attributes these are now routinely
removed and considered PII personally
identifiable information when you
release medical data but but there's
other ways so further work that
Latanya has been doing for example shows
that knowing a little bit about the
wizard date and the diagnose that you
could get say for example from a
newspaper article about somebody who had
an accident they probably went to this
the nearby hospital on this state so you
have one tuple of visit date and
prognosis for this person and from that
you can actually get a lot more
information you can get their whole
medical record so I guess this is the
tension that differential privacy is
meant to address there's private data
releasing it carries a lot of risk I'll
give you a few more examples of this
kind of privacy attacks then I'll give
you a formal privacy definition that
tries to protect against these kinds of
and these another kinds of attacks and
then I'll give you a little bit a little
flavor of how you can actually go about
designing differentially private angry
let me just so just to reiterate we saw
two examples of data sets that contain
sensitive information about individuals
but they are there's a lot more there
are everywhere
governments have them businesses have
them and as we saw analyzing these data
sets can be very valuable we do want to
learn that it was a Broad Street pump
that was causing cholera we want to be
able to learn from analyzing data sets
that smoking causes cancers but at the
same time we don't necessarily want to
learn from the data set or from the
analysis whether I smoke or not and
there are many good reasons to to
guarantee privacy I won't get into that
let me tell you about a few more stories
that illustrates other aspects of this
of the privacy risks
how many of you heard of the Netflix
price so that looks price for those you
haven't heard was this competition that
it's one of the first big popular
crowdsourcing data analysis competitions
where they basically released a large
dataset containing a couple of hundred
million movie ratings of half a million
people and the task force to kind of use
this large data set to be able to
predict how certain individual will how
much this individual will like a movie
that wasn't actually like another
candidate movie
so they releases it a set movie movie
rental records are actually sensitive
not just from the business point of view
but also actually legally protected and
so they did actually remove all personal
identifiable information in this case
what they released was something very
simple basically it was a large matrix
where the rows were people the columns
were movies and the populated entries
was how what was the rating of this
person for this movie
of course the persons were all just
replaced by random random numbers the
movies were movies like a movies don't
need to have privacy
and I guess it was two weeks in this
case before an an and and shmatte ago
published a paper showing that you could
actually identify people in this in this
matrix if you know a little bit about
them so if I know for example three
movies that you watched along with the
dates you watch them on or the week that
you watch them on which for example you
could have told me about a movie you
watched if you were my friend that's
enough to completely identify a person
in this database and learn about other
movies that they washed and may not have
told you about
and I guess what this example
illustrates is it's something more more
worrying so in the case of medical
records the auxilary information that
allowed the annotation was stuff like
zip code and gender which it's
reasonable to say that your zip code
probably is not important data about if
I wanted to do some if I wanted to learn
whether smoking causes cancers I mean
don't need to learn your zip code to be
able to do that so one could hope to
share datasets with more with these
fields retract it and get some utility
out of it in this case all that was
published was this matrix if you want to
share this matrix
there's no retraction here that could
have prevented this kind of attack and
still allowed any reasonable entrance
movie movies lately yeah the movies were
permeated randomly
okay good point so they could have done
that but that would severely restrict
utility so in this case what was also
useful to actually build the
recommendation system and was true in
all the winning entries all any entry
that made it to the top of the list at
the property that they used not just the
the matrix but also use the fact that
this is a John Wayne movie if you like
one John Wayne movie you probably liked
the other ones as well so attributes of
the movies itself were useful
information to build the recommendation
system
so I guess the model from this is
there's obviously information in this
world thinks that you don't publish but
people may have access to it may come
from the water rolls it may come from
what you tell me about what you watched
all right may even come from IMDb's in
fact in their attack they showed that
you could identify IMDB users from what
they rated on IMDB and kind of guarding
against all the information is is very
difficult it's if you want to think
about data set release as an isolated
problem it's it makes it easier but it
doesn't actually solve the problem
because there are alternative data sets
they do exist here's one last story so
this is this paper that's now known as
Homer a tell I don't expect you to read
the title what this paper basically
showed was
okay so do we know what G was study is
genome-wide Association study
so genome-wide Association studies are
these these studies where you try to
figure out how your genotype how your
genes except sir
affect your likelihood of getting a
certain disease and the way you do such
a study is to simplify a bit you collect
a large population of people who don't
have a disease a large population of
people who do have a disease you
sequence these guys genome you sequence
these guys you know and then you look
for correlations between certain what
are called snips and the disease and if
you see a large correlation that
probably suggests that this gene has
something to do with the disease and
then you could investigate further so
these have become I guess very frequent
in the last decade or so and for a while
and is acquired you to actually share a
fair amount of raw data when you ran
such a study so if NIH funded your study
you were required to publish say all
one-way marginals all correlations not
just the ones that you found to be
significant but actually all of them and
what this paper showed was that if you
do that if I have access to all these
one my marginals and if I know your DNA
say from the glass that you just used to
drink water from I could actually figure
out whether you are in the control group
or the disease group so even though all
that's being published is this very very
aggregate information over thousands of
people we are averaging the frequency of
a certain snip
the fact that I have actually millions
of these one-way marginals even with
some noise added is sufficient to
actually identify people in this
database
and I guess this is what happened as
soon so basically even before this paper
was published and I actually flipped its
requirements and prohibited people from
sharing these one-way marginal thing so
I guess what this example illustrates is
that even very large scale aggregate
data which looks completely innocuous
can be actually very revealing and I
guess I didn't get into more examples
but there are examples where even when
you don't actually publish anything you
just act based on some database even
that can be sometimes revealing in all
of these cases think one thing that's
worth noting is that the experts who
were publishing the data had all the
incentive to worry about privacy and yet
even the best known techniques at the
time were not enough to actually get to
give the privacy give any privacy
guarantee and sometimes the reason for
that is I would argue that all these
approaches were somewhat ad-hoc you come
up with a way to how you could attack
the system and then you put one bandit
to try to fix it and you repeat but
because because our imagination is
limited it's very hard to actually use
this approach to really guard against
all possible attacks
so I guess differential privacy is one
approach to to solving this problem so
let me define that next so
so I guess one kind of insight that came
from I would say cryptography is that
privacy is not a property of what you
publish it's a property of the mechanism
you use to publish in the same way that
in cryptography the it's not the
ciphertext that secure it's the fact
that the ciphertext is generated using
some mechanism that makes it secure
so privacy will be a property of the
mechanism that's used to generate the
data so it will be convenient to think
of the of an interactive setting though
we don't really need that requirement
and we'll kind of use this to publish
things later but imagine you have an
analyst that's trying to learn something
about the database yes the database and
we there's a curator sitting in between
that takes questions from the analyst
and gives responses
so you can ask it how many people in
this database smoked and got canceled
how many people did not smoke and got
canceled and so on and based on all
those answers you can build your model
learnt stuff what the curator will do is
so the curator is kind of a wall between
the analyst and the database it will get
the real answers and potentially ads and
then in fact in most cases add some
noise to the answers before returning
them so to define differential privacy
it's convenient to think of two
universes there is a blue universe where
I am in the database there's one row in
the database that comes that contains
all of my data and there's the red
universe where I've gone in and
completely erased my data from the
database so here I exist I am in the
database here I don't exist I am NOT in
the database
what differential privacy would
intuitively say is that the analyst
that's interacting with the curator it
can't tell whether it's in the blue
universe or the red universe based on
the interactions
it's the analyst is not able to figure
out whether I'm actually even in the
database or not these two words look
identical to the analyst
and I guess it's reasonable to say that
in this universe in the red universe
when I'm not even in the database well
in this universe the database doesn't
even know I exist
it can't possibly leak anything about me
the blue universe looks almost the same
as this one this is why it's a privacy
definition yeah question
so if for example you know me personally
and you know that I smoke before the
analyst before the analysis happened you
didn't know that smoking has anything to
do with cancer after the analysis you
learned that smoking causes cancer and
therefore you can infer that I am now
likely to get cancer that is an
attribute of me guess what I would argue
is that this the secret that smoking
causes cancer is not my secret to keep
so so you could distinguish between
secrets that I have which are my secrets
and there are things which are my
secrets but other other people have them
other people know them I have no control
in whether or not those get released or
not
what differential privacy guarantees is
that things about me that I have will
not be revealed so I think that there
may be valid situations where you may
not actually even want to do a certain
study but whether or not we want to do a
study that tells us whether smoking
causes cancer is a societal decision I
have no control on whether that study
happens or not what I can control is
whether I participate in the study or
not this definition says that by
participating in the study I do not
change the likelihood of any event and
this actually is a very crucial
distinction if you want a guarantee that
the adversity can not learn anything
about me whatsoever there's actually a
theorem that says that you cannot
actually give any information whatsoever
so what differential privacy is is an
attempt to kind of tease apart this this
distinction between I guess what Frank
calls secrets that are that I have
versus secrets about me if I don't want
the secret
I have no agency to protect it
differential privacy will not
necessarily protect it so I guess
there's a lot of discussion on this
question there's a very nice blog post
by Frank McSherry that I would recommend
you read that basically addresses
exactly this question but any more
questions yeah yes so I guess I'll get
to that yeah okay so let me tell you
formally what the definition is as I
said it basically says that the
distribution so this curator will be a
randomized algorithm this definition
says that the distribution in the blue
universe is almost the same as the
distribution in the red universe
formally there is a parameter called
epsilon so epsilon differential privacy
says that this likelihood of this event
happening of any event happening in the
blue universe is within eetu the epsilon
of the same event happening in the red
universe and vice-versa so for any two
databases that differ in one individual
by addition or deletion any event is
almost as likely in the blue universe as
it is in the red
so this parameter epsilon measures how
much privacy is being leaked we'll think
of it as the privacy loss we will
normally think of it as a small constant
so e to the epsilon is like 1 plus
Epsilon
we'll also look at a relaxation of this
definition called epsilon Delta
differential privacy where you allow a
small probability of kind of failure so
you should think of Delta as being very
very small crypt as small as the
probability of your password being
leaked so this is kind of at least
polynomially small or even smaller
epsilon is a small constant so I guess
this Delta doesn't really change at
least my intuitive understanding of the
definition by much but technically it
turns out to be very useful to have a
very small slack kill divergence no it's
not quite as weak as total so I guess so
without the Delta it's a max divergence
guarantee so Cal divergence kind of
measures the expectation of the the top
this is the L infinity version of KL
divergence with the Delta it's sort of
like a delta slack version of L infinity
okay so there are two kind of nice
properties of this definition first you
can take an output of a differentially
private mechanism and then you can do
whatever you want with it you can add
one to it you can run a join with your
favorite water list you do whatever it
stays differentially private to define
to give the definition I didn't have to
uh tur the words auxilary information
this definition by itself says no matter
what of the information you have if you
do anything with output of a
differentially private mechanism any
post-processing preserves differential
privacy
the second important property is
composability so if you run one
differentially private mechanism and
then you run another differentially
private mechanism the sum total of the
two the total interaction is still
differentially private the privacy
parameter epsilon kind of degrades
gracefully so what this allows us to do
is to sort of use small differentially
private building blocks and put them
together and reason about the the union
of these building blocks yes so if you
keep us running an arbitrarily large
number of differentially private
algorithms then your epsilon will go to
infinity and you won't have any privacy
so epsilon is kind of your kind of the
currency
think of it as since we are in Berkeley
if you if you spend a small amount of
money on something it seems small but if
you keep doing it over and over and over
again it can become large somehow after
every query kind of video on demises
things so the epsilon suddenly
accumulate so that would be nice but
unfortunately at least in many settings
we know that they do accumulate in the
sense that if you answer a lot of
questions about the same database either
the answers become very very inaccurate
over time or you essentially leak the
whole database so there are privacy
attacks showing that even ignoring
differential privacy if you want any
notion of privacy you do need to either
control the number of questions you
answer or the accuracy with which you
answered yes so there's some work in
those lines in the single party setting
it we don't have any evidence that it
helps there are settings where it does
help so if I have a database and you
have a database and we want to jointly
compute some function then assuming some
computational restriction on the
adversary does allow us to help a lot
Oh Delta yeah good so actually I'll say
more about composability later in the
talk it's actually a lot better than
this when you compose multiple times but
one more thing to add to answer to a
previous question the other property
that I didn't write down here is that
the way the definition is written it's
easy to see that if you remove three
people from the database then you have
sort of three epsilon differential
privacy the small groups of people can
be removed from the database they still
have so families still has privacy the
community will not have privacy because
we want to learn something about the
community so I guess this is a slide
which essentially was to have the
discussion that we sort of already had
differential privacy does not say that
your beliefs about the world do not
change if you came from Mars and thought
that humans were octopuses and had eight
feet after interacting with the
databases with the database you will
learn that I'm actually I only have two
feet but that deduction would happen
even if I was not in the database and in
some sense that is not my secret to keep
and I guess Absalon actually accumulates
over time it with them it's how much you
can how many queries you can answer so
let me actually quickly give you one
example of how you can get differential
privacy so imagine you are trying to
answer a simple query such as a count
query you are asking how many people in
the database smoke some overall people
love some predicates some 0 and
predicates the private approximation to
that this is is basically you output the
function plus noise drawn from this
Laplace distribution which is basically
this distribution here it's an
exponential distribution symmetrized
why does this give differential privacy
well if you look at the blue universe
versus the red universe the correct
answer can differ by at most one so I'm
drawing in one case from this
distribution in the other case I'm
drawing from the same distribution
shifted by at most one the way this
function is defined you have it's easy
to see that the property it has a
property that the ratio of these of the
density at any point is at most epsilon
where epsilon I guess depends on this
lambda here if I you surrender the
generator pass yes are yours yeah that's
yeah so I guess I'm kind of brushing
under the rug the issue of how you're
generating the randomness so we are in
the model where you have access to a
random number generator is um to be
secure
we have to remember what I drew from the
distribution if I'm asked okay good
question so slightly no you don't have
to remember if you ask if you are asked
the same question I could again and add
fresh randomness and give a new answer
doing that will cost me in privacy so if
I am actually able to remember answers
to previous questions that does allow me
to kind of get a better privacy utility
trade-off and that's just that's kind of
a much more general statement and if you
have you're asking say many many queries
like this being able to correlate the
answers to these questions allows me to
actually get much much less noise than
you would think otherwise
yeah so there's this was I guess
somewhat surprising at first starting
with work by Avram Liggett and rot but
in fact now we sort of know that there
is sort of a big gap just shift all day
so having he to the epsilon is created
here that's actually just an artifact of
the definition yes well yes and no so
having an epsilon in the exponent allows
me to add them add Epsilon's if I had 1
plus epsilon I would have to do a more
complex yes so I guess the composition
theorem becomes more more ugly and
actually harder to reason about
so note that this distribution actually
has expected value which is quite small
something like 1 over Epsilon if you
have n people in the database just your
sampling noise would be square root n so
this is this is quite small you can get
differential privacy without using
losing much in utility so epsilon is
point 1 to 1 alright then you have to
use very small Epsilon therefore 1 over
epsilon is not such a small number so we
think of say epsilon as 0.1 it's 1 over
epsilon is 10 if you have a 10,000
people database noise of 10 and the
answer is not a lot probably 1.1 X 1
plus X when X is small so it's 1 point 0
1 the second order term is like x
squared over 2 so for 0.1 it's
and I mean I guess I think there's a
longer discussion to be had on what's a
good value of Epsilon I personally think
an epsilon of one is not a bad value if
I'm not in the database the chance of
something bad happening to me is I would
say zero or pretty close to zero if that
double sort gets increased by a factor
of ten that's probably not such a bad
thing
yeah that's this question so this is a
diff no way is happening on the some
rights okay and people they would they
were randomly sampled you'd expect kind
of square root of n random kind of
anyway if this last day
skip over other another building block
so let me say a little bit about
composition so what I described was
basic composition which says that if you
run T mechanisms in sequence each of
which is epsilon delta differentially
private it's very easy to show that the
the sequence is something like epsilon T
delta T differentially private there's
actually a stronger composition theorem
which sort of replaces this T by a
square root T this term is negligible
usually this Delta goes up by a factor
of T but Delta is usually much smaller
so in some sense you don't actually pay
epsilon times T only pepsiman times
through T there's a better composition
that does happen and in fact using kind
of moment generating functions you can
actually sometimes improve on that as
well so for many distributions of choice
if so I guess I'll not get into this but
you can define a privacy loss random
variable which is uniformly bounded for
pure differential privacy and bounded
with high probability for epsilon Delta
differential privacy for many distribute
for many mechanisms you can actually
control the log of the moment generating
function of this this random variable
the log of the MGF itself composes which
is actually very nice so you can do all
your composition in this moment
generating function domain and then you
can translate to epsilon Delta using
Markov inequality
you can do a lot more once you have
these building blocks you can put them
together to do lots of more interesting
things people have built recommendation
systems such as Netflix challenge you
can build decision trees you can do
principle component analysis you can
even do you can generate data that's
looks like trail data you can even do
some neural network training with while
guaranteeing differential privacy here
are some pictures that I will not get
into there's also a large number of
connections the differential privacy has
too many other fields so I think it's a
very rich and interesting area of
research and I guess with that will
basically just summarize so just to
reiterate I think there's plenty of
evidence in the form of privacy attacks
that just ad hoc approaches to making
data private is just broken differential
privacy is a strong principled way of
getting around this this issue and you
can actually do a large number of fairly
interesting non-trivial data analysis
tasks while guaranteeing differential
privacy Thanks
yeah you tell me a little bit about so
it depends a lot on the size of your
data set so for but it I mean I guess
for modern large data sets it's pretty
small so it gives one example okay so I
guess I'll just show you okay then I'll
just say so say for example for the M
nest data set where kind of the simple
neural network that we train gets
something like ninety eight point three
percent accuracy we can get 95 with
epsilon equals two and this is a
relatively small data sets only fifty
thousand training images we would expect
that when you have larger data sets your
overhead would be smaller but that's
kind of a question that will need some
more empirical work I think often when
you have larger data sets you that's a
very difficult situation so for a few
hundred I think most of our techniques
actually would incur non-trivial loss in
accuracy because I mean if you're if you
exactly knew one question that you want
it to us we can probably answer it very
quickly typical data analysis you want
to run a sequence of queries and then
you your even the better composition
theorems actually add up okay thank you